[Music]
oh it's you glad you can make it is she
up yet oh she's up she's ready to go and
by Go I mean go as in go check the world
out what you going to do what you going
to say I got that cover please relax
just do your
job good morning mayy wavy happy
birthday my little mouse thank you Dad I
know it's my birthday I have so much fun
planned woohoo but first we we go catch
some scorpions together just the two of
us yes D Dad please let me speak there's
something we have to talk about you want
to go out into the world you can't aha I
knew you were going to say that but Dad
you gave me your word and you know that
I know that a Dracula's word is sacred
that our trust is the core of our wait
what I said you can go you're just
playing with me no no no no you're old
enough to drive a hearse now you're old
enough to make your own choices you can
go holy rabies holy rabies
W stop wait a second sweet things where
are you going oh well I'm going to
paradise and this is some stuff that I
thought I would need Paradise yeah you
know it's that place out there where you
and Mom met ATI Wanda says you two were
just like Zing I don't know from Zing
where did you find that card in one of
your drawers why won't you ever tell me
about how you met it's actually Hawaii
ha what look honey I know you're excited
but everyone has gone to Great Lanes to
come see you on your birthday I know
they always do aren't it getting a
little old for these parties I love them
but I really want to see new things
maybe meet somebody my
age come on no no don't do that don't
give me the pouty bad face okay there is
a human Village just a little ways past
the cemetery you could go there and be
back in like 30 minutes or so it should
be plenty for your first time well it's
not hwi but I guess it's still
technically out there okay okay
[Music]
okay thanks for trusting me of course my
little one I gave you my
word I thought I found a love but she
was just a fling and then I at a girl
felt a different thing it's like a hit
in the ring like you're pulled by string
can't breathe like you're Ching on a
chicken wing it was a thing called a
zing and I wanted to sing and listen to
the Ballads of the man Nam sting lady
looks in your eyes and it suddenly
spring like when in The Lion
[Music]
King singing in the rain now I'm feeling
no pain it's a real time C
CU you're my
dream D ready to throw down no no I just
came closer to to hear you better oh
come on just give it a try all right
maybe just a little so listen all you
sing is from here to Beijing you better
cat the boxing get ready to clean was
M
Wasing and it was only one lady in the
for me you better know one thing the
only thing you're going to sling is a
wed
ring
singing in now I don't have I'm winging
from The Zing that we Shar singing in
the ring now I'm feeling
noain
[Music]
of going knock you right out of that
ring bettering Happ pay ATT to the
undead King
y'all
[Music]
peekaboo no no no no no I didn't mean to
startle you my little
[Music]
baby har Little Vampire don't say a word
Papa's going to bite the head off a
[Music]
bird I want to kiss your tool I want to
kiss your
[Music]
tool nice but maybe a little more square
footage I want a lot of monsters that
[Music]
here I'm going to cat you little M I'm
going to catch
you what out there oh we never go out
there
ever and then the monsters ran away and
were forced into hiding but Harry the
human found them and jumped out from
under their bed I'm scared and burned
their clothes
and beat their toes and took their
candy don't take my candy baby Claus you
don't need to be frightened I promised
your mommy I would protect you
forever my beautiful
maybe let me wipe all your poop
away those humans are
nasty so with Daddy you will
stay and if a human tries to harm you
I'll simply
say because your daddy's girl daddy's
girl just bend the legs and push off
trust me
[Music]
mouse look at you faster baby faster you
got it my little voodoo
[Music]
[Laughter]
doll yeah it's a mess back
[Music]
[Applause]
there
welcome to Hotel
Transylvania human free since 1898 your
safest destination take an itinerary I
have personally designed a spectacular
schedule of events all leading to my
daughter's birthday Extravaganza
tomorrow we always look forward to
coming every year count we enjoy the
safety so much of course that's why we
built it yes good evening thank you
Marty you look pale as
well sir we have an urgent plumbing
issue Plumbing on it Mr G again there is
a clog toilet in room
348 it's okay we all get stomach aches
Mr
[Music]
Bigfoot hey kids reel it in you're only
supposed to make Mom and Dad
Miserable Now now is that any way to
behave this is a hotel not a
cemetery uncle
track track how are you Wayne my old
friend couldn't wait for this weekend
always great to be out of the Shadows
for a couple days the family looks
beautiful let me just clean up their
fields
[Music]
housekeeping Frankie my boy look at you
still traveling by mail Mr Cheapo huh
it's not a money thing I have a plain
phobia okay I mean at any moment those
engines could catch fire yeah yeah fire
bad we
know AUST this for head come on does
that look like Frankenstein's head hey
dra buddy what's going on with your cape
there what do you mean who pitched me
guilty you're irresistible yes very
amusing Invisible Man hello great to see
you I never get old
ha missed me miss me miss me miss me
okay you win hold this bacon why am I
holding
BAC no get him
off here comes the
party hello Murray dra what's up buddy
the sand muray the sand always is with
the
sand wolfy w
hey I love this guy he always bringing
it Full Tilt you're looking skinny too
now that you're just ahead okay you'll
pay for
[Music]
that so what's up dra the hotel is
looking off the hook hey guys watch
this by the way you were right about
those directions oh good good yeah I
took the Tigers through the Nile and
there was absolutely no traffic
oh my goodness leard if you really look
That Hideous I don't think I can hang
out with you guys what's the deal is
this a party pick up a phone I don't
care if Johnny said it's a cool app
Johnny's still new here now Pard head
did you call a hearse for the gremlin
Birds no you're checking your Facebook
page again dra I told the guys social
media is the best way to promote the
hotel right Clifton
so dra I wanted to go through some
thoughts I had as your new human
relations coordina and co-assistant sure
it's a real job now that cheap excuse to
keep Mavis happy so you'll never leave
here right so I was thinking since we
have so many humans now maybe uh update
some of the acts like maybe the magician
what's wrong with Harry 3i well he might
be a little old school for the humans
tell me sir what was your card uh the
three of
Spades is this you're C my friend
whoa no Harry's great can't blame Harry
for the crowd not being Hipp okay what
about Wayne Wayne are you not he's my
boy he maybe something other than tennis
okay so what you want to do is lift the
racket right on impact so you get that
nice Top Spin try and hit
one what is that what's the noise it
it's on me it's just the cell phone I
got you Clifton's sending you a text so
you can practice how to write
[Music]
back what it's not doing it I got it
dear
dra now you can text Clifton all right
fine how do you do this maybe it's your
fingernails it's easy look I'll text
Mavis psyched for date night see and now
look she texted right back got to cancel
can't leave
Dennis okay are we never allowed to be
alone again I need to feel loved too and
sent okay all that taught me is that
you're pathetic yeah got it maybe you
should just get Bluetooth okay Bluetooth
come over
here so now what
why are we doing this you'd rather be
listening to those putrid new songs what
happened to Michael roer corpse aore or
old MC whale wolf had an
axe we shouldn't be up here dra who's
ready to fly me me like a superhero
better like a vampire this thing is
rickety you know maybe the kid isn't
supposed to Fly Quiet this is how they
learn you throw them and they figure it
out it's how I was taught I want to fly
now ah the bad you know papa is right
here if you need him uh I can't watch
this please don't here we
go he's still not flying he
will still not it'll
happen a tall tower that's why it's good
you you should get him he's going to
fall to his death he's taking his
time track I did that my first time he's
getting too close to the
ground you know what he's not going to
fly I told you Papa's always here for
you again again
oh dear oh my devil we're going to have
to report this you mean to the papers I
guess it was pretty cool but I'm not
about getting pressed no sir I mean the
authorities I I can't not report child
endangerment whoa listen to me that was
fun you're singing his child
endangerment should we go down and help
him nope I told him this was nuts he's
on his own we have to call the boy's
mother no that ain't happening his
mother's already Nazi cuckoo I have to
follow
protocol you will not follow protocol
I'm a vampire I can't be
hypnotized right now please don't make
me call the police no one's calling
nobody stop driv roll stop driv roll we
make that
Happ are we bad guys Papa track
bad no you're the best kid in the world
We Didn't Start the Fire it was the
tower that's a very unsafe Tower you're
lucky we don't call the authorities
let's go my hero keep eyes I'm Batman to
the
Batmobile yes to
the stop squirming why are you doing
this because this is wrong why doesn't
anybody get that humans don't belong
with monsters you're wrong I am not I am
holding you hostage and me and my crew
are going to tear that human hugging
hotel to shreds you can't really why not
keep keep why keep will make Papa track
sad oh s and what are you going to do
about it I don't know you know why you
don't know keepa you're just a weak let
her
[Music]
p
what was that Dennis we're
coming you okay Winnie yes
[Music]
mying
a there's his mean
[Music]
friend oh this is it'll be
fun
[Music]
hey didn't do
that you Rock Den the KY
[Music]
[Applause]
rolls get it I'm
coming
I knew all that practice would pay
[Music]
[Applause]
off that's right you better fly away
[Music]
you look ravishing oh uh thank you I
just
W so um does Captain Erica have a last
name uh uh uh uh oh guacamole Erica
guacamole that's so International no
guacamole for us to share oh how
beautiful is that full moon tonight look
right behind
[Music]
you the food here is to die
for
holy moly that was a lot of
guacamole are you feeling all right
totally fine why no
reason oh there must have been garlic in
the guacamole oh no isn't that deadly
for you no no no it's just
that garlic
[Music]
intolerant
was that
you oh yeah dolphin
[Applause]
Turin whoa hi Mama Hi Papa hi hi oh hey
there
adho is my dad in there too oh
don't worry I'm over here blah blah
blah no papa dra's not here he's on his
date
[Music]
dat please forgive me I I'm just very
nervous you
see I haven't had a date since my wife
died how old was your daughter she was
just an infant it was hard being a
single that but I I did my
[Music]
best I never knew my mother either or my
father oh I'm so sorry who raised you my
great-grandfather I basically grew up on
this ship that's why you're a captain
yeah it's all I've ever known it was
just
expected you know a family thing I
understand family is everything you have
to honor the past but we make our own
[Music]
future dad
mayis
Johnny Captain Erica and I were just
discussing the hospitality in the hisory
you know just work stuff you're working
now this is supposed to be a vacation a
family vacation I I should really go do
Cy
things having fun oh I'm having even
more fun now that you're here you know
Dad I feel really lucky to have this
time with you all of us together it's
really special me too spider monkey now
are you ready for me to destroy you in
Monster Ball woohoo Monster Ball
come on Papa oh bring it on for I am
king of family
fun all right who is ready to get
Pummel I got to warn you I played second
team Co at intral volleyball at Santa
Cruz sure pal whatever you say everybody
just please watch the hair watch the
hair oh let's go let's do this oh my
gosh this is going to be so much fun ha
get ready here comes the
[Applause]
pain not the not the
here no no no no no no
[Applause]
no Captain Erica you are needed on death
next up bye-bye
Dracula okay
baby
oh baby I got this hey there
monsters yeah what I
say we are arriving at our our first
destination the underwater
volcano everyone grab your scuba gear
and get ready to explore the wonders of
the
sea especially you Count
Dracula you see that found she likes you
oh no no no no no no no no that sounds
like a zing in full effect oh no no no
no no no no oh yes yes yes yes yes I'm
just here to have family fun family
family fun
fun
tonight I just to take
[Music]
you bring up to the
mo girl what y'all trying to
do 24 carat magic in
the
[Music]
look who back again they don't don't
know as soon as we walk
[Music]
in girl what y trying to do what you're
trying to
do magic
[Applause]
[Music]
up to
theing to
[Music]
[Applause]
do trying to
[Music]
[Applause]
do or good
Dracula you know it van hing's beats are
controlling the Giant Octopus thingy if
there's one thing I hate it's an evil DJ
we need positive
energy
[Music]
get ready for a DJ battle you just carry
all that stuff around with you once a
bar mitz for DJ always a bar mitz for DJ
we're going to use good music to defeat
his evil music what trust me I know the
tunes but you've got the power all right
okay opening song needs to be off the
shizak got it play
this
I'm picking up Good Vibrations she's
giving me the
exitation
[Music]
I'm what is that
noise I like this one this feels
good
[Music]
wa this music is too powerful we're
going to need something even more
positive now
[Music]
dra so don't
worry be happy don't worry be happy has
a nice
message dog
wor be
happy I've had enough of this nonsense
[Music]
n
he